il est 15h vous êtes en vacances les
fenêtres sont ouvertes le soleil chauffe
la pièce et au loin vous entendez la
télévision vous avez peut-être déjà vécu
cette scène et oui peu importe si on
aime le sport ou non on connaît tous de
près ou de loin le Tour de France
symbole du début de l'été et pourtant en
dehors de ces images de maillot jaune
d'échapper dans la montagne ou même de
chutes
au-delà donc de l'aspect sportif le tour
cache aussi beaucoup de secrets
notamment des histoires d'argent et
d'influence que l'on va voir aujourd'hui
dans cette vidéo on va donc parler de
tout ce qui entoure l'événement des
sommes très importantes que dépensent
les villes du précieux livre que doivent
suivre les caméraman ou encore du
mythique Bob Cochonou oui oui on va voir
tout ça aujourd'hui bref installez-vous
confortablement prenez une petite
limonade ou autre chose et on est parti
ensemble révision
nous sommes tout juste six mois avant le
tour dans une grande conférence filmée
et retransmise dans le monde entier
l'annonce est faite cette année le Tour
passera par l'Espagne Bordeaux ou encore
clairement il tournera le dos au nord de
la France dans la foulée les critiques
fuses parce que oui contrairement à ce
que son nom semble indiqué et bien le
Tour de France ne fait pas ou ne fait
plus en tout cas exactement le tour de
la France c'était le cas donc à l'époque
mais aujourd'hui la distance est limitée
à 3500 km il faut donc choisir la
Bretagne ou l'Alsace la côte atlantique
ou la Méditerranée le sud ou le nord
c'est une question de spectacle mais
c'est aussi une question d'argent vous
allez le voir tout de suite
celui qui choisit tout cela s'est amori
Sport Organisation l'entreprise donc qui
organise le tour et pour vous donner une
idée de l'importance de cette entreprise
voici un aperçu de ce qu'elle possède le
journal L'Équipe le rallye Dakar le
Marathon de Paris l'Open de France
paris-roubet ou encore parinis ça fait
beaucoup là non donc à Maurice port
organisation décide deux ans à l'avance
du parcours en fonction des villes qui
candidatent et pour vous donner un
exemple oui il faut de la montagne car
c'est dans les montagnes que les plus
grands exploits du Tour de France se
font et que les écarts se creusent
problème ce n'est pas donné à tout le
monde certains territoires n'ont pas de
montagne alors lorsqu'il candidate et
bien il mise sur d'autres choses ça peut
être le vent très important ça peut être
les ponts ça peut être le paysage avec
la mer etc une candidature peut prendre
du temps avant d'être validé parfois 5 à
10 ans certaines villes reçoivent
plusieurs fois la visite d'ASO pour
observer vérifier leur territoire le
parcours potentiel etc et une fois que
les candidatures sont retenues et bien
les villes doivent passer à la caisse et
en l'occurrence pour les villes et bien
ça coûte très cher
aucun chiffre officiel n'a été dévoilé
par les organisateurs du Tour de France
mais selon Le Figaro ou encore BFM TV le
prix varie légèrement entre 60 et 80 000
euros pour accueillir le départ de
l'étape entre 100 000 et 120 000 euros
pour accueillir l'arrivée de l'étape et
plus de 160 000 pour accueillir à la
fois le départ et l'arrivée il y a une
auto passage que les villes ou les
villages qui sont juste traversés par le
tour non rien à payer autrement ça
commencerait à être assez compliqué bon
mais ça c'est des prix de départ ou
d'arrivée pour des étapes classiques
disons au sein du Tour en l'occurrence
le prix peut atteindre plusieurs
millions d'euros si la ville veut
t'accueillir le grand départ autrement
dit donc le premier départ du Tour de
France pour le grand départ à Brest en
2021 par exemple le chèque versé était
de 1,5 millions d'euros et en plus de ce
paiement et bien les villes doivent
faire face à d'autres dépenses les
travaux sur la route des constructions
de parking de la décoration de la la
ville des achats de kit aussi pour les
commerçants l'organisation d'une
cérémonie bref beaucoup beaucoup de
choses qu'on imagine pas forcément on
peut le voir d'ailleurs sur ces
documents de la région Bretagne c'est
mon temps peuvent atteindre parfois des
dizaines ou des centaines de milliers
d'euros supplémentaires alors vous
l'imaginez pour certaines communes ces
prix peuvent paraître très élevés
certaines sont donc aider par leur
département ou leur région c'est le cas
par exemple de la région Bretagne pour
les quatre étapes du Tour 2021 qui sont
passés par la Bretagne résultat
certaines villes sont obligées parfois
de faire des sacrifices pour payer la
note pour le journal Le Figaro par
exemple le maire de Chorges commune de
2600 habitants dans les Hautes-Alpes qui
a accueilli l'arrivée d'une étape du
Tour en 2013 explique avoir été obligé
de tailler dans les dépenses budgétaires
et de diminuer les subventions aux
associations pour accueillir justement
cette étape du Tour et pourtant malgré
ce coût 250 communes chaque année se
porte candidate pour accueillir l'une
des étapes du Tour de France
[Musique]
et en effet pour une ville accueillir le
Tour de France ça peut être extrêmement
rentable déjà la ville doit loger et
nourrir toutes les personnes qui font le
tour en quelque sorte c'est 176 coureurs
450 accompagnateurs 600 publicités près
de 400 journalistes et j'en passe au
total 4500 personnes se déplacent chaque
jour
1550 lits sont réservés chaque jour pour
l'organisation et pour les équipes et
tout ça et bien c'est forcément une
aubaine pour les restaurateurs et pour
les hôteliers de la ville qui vont faire
forcément sur très peu de temps un très
gros chiffre évidemment assez près de
4500 personnes il faut aussi ajouter les
spectateurs qui viennent en très grand
nombre
pour son étape à Brest en 2021 et malgré
le covid encore présent bien la ville a
compté 52 000 touristes venus voir le
tour et selon la région Bretagne chaque
jour un spectateur du Tour de France
dépense aux alentours
70 euros sur le territoire cet argent
est bien forcément c'est de l'argent qui
est dépensé dans les commerces de la
région les restaurants les boulangeries
les hôtels etc etc au total selon la
région Bretagne qui défend donc son
bilan pour 1 euro investi ce serait
trois euros de retomber économique sur
le territoire des chiffres confirmés par
ailleurs par les villes d'Albi et de
Saint-Étienne même si on imagine que
dans le cas d'un village comme Georges
par exemple c'est pas forcément le cas
avec les retombées économiques qui
peuvent être un peu plus difficiles quoi
qu'il en soit donc pour certaines villes
il y aurait donc un énorme intérêt
financier pour booster l'économie de son
territoire mais cela dit et bien ce
n'est pas tout
[Musique]
en effet on ne peut pas parler de ses
coulisses sans parler de l'intérêt en
visibilité le Tour de France c'est aussi
une immense vitrine pour donner une
image donc c'est comme si on envoyait
une carte postale avec un beau paysage
de sa région après de 3,5 milliards de
personnes dont le monde au total durant
toute la compétition en comparaison
l'euro 2020 de football a fait 5,2
milliards de téléspectateurs dans le
monde alors certes ça reste plus pour
l'Euro et puis en plus la configuration
n'est pas la même évidemment entre une
diffusion d'un tour de France pendant un
mois et la diffusion d'une compétition
comme l'euro mais tout de même le Tour
de France à ses avantages en matière de
territoire en effet le paysage est
quasiment aussi important que la course
en elle-même d'ailleurs selon un sondage
audoxa pour Winamax et RTL 50% des
téléspectateurs du Tour de France sont
là pour regarder avant tout le
patrimoine et les paysages français
France Télévisions qui produit et
diffuse le tour
des hélicoptères pour tourner donc ces
images et dans une interview au 1 Hebdo
et bien l'un des caméraman du Tour qui
se trouve donc dans l'hélicoptère
explique que tous les paysages qu'ils
doivent filmer sont prévus au kilomètre
près ils doivent suivre en fait un
roadbook préparé un an en avance qui
liste donc les paysages et les
patrimoines qui peuvent être mises en
valeur sur le parcours et c'est beau
paysage ces châteaux ces maisons
atypiques ils appellent ça les beauties
et il peut y en avoir jusqu'à 50 par
épreuve et d'ailleurs dans l'hélicoptère
on se retrouve à avoir deux caméras il y
en a une pour le paysage et l'autre
quand même pour la course et pour les
coureurs l'objectif c'est donc de créer
des vrais cartes postales en direct à la
télévision des images qui vont être vu
évidemment à la télé prenez beaucoup de
plaisir personnellement en tout cas
avoir ces beaux paysages au début de
l'été quand il faisait très chaud comme
ça et que je regardais ça à voir aussi
quand parfois ça passait près de chez
moi auprès de chez mes grands-parents et
puis forcément et bien ça va attirer du
monde après coup on peut que des
touristes étrangers ou français vont
vouloir aller découvrir telle ou telle
région bref c'est un immense coup de
publicité pour un territoire bien plus
utile donc qu'un spot publicitaire
surtout pour des régions le plus souvent
assez peu mis en avant de base bon après
cette surmédiatisation elle peut
entraîner parfois des problèmes et des
dérives on peut par exemple citer les
spectateurs qui tentent de se faire
remarquer le long des routes parfois au
péril de la sécurité des coureurs
exemple avec cette spectatrice en 2021
mais heureusement le plus souvent ça se
passe bien bref cette visibilité elle
intéresse les territoires et les villes
françaises mais de plus en plus malgré
le fait que ça s'appelle le Tour de
France et l'intéresse aussi et bien des
villes à l'étranger
sur les 110 éditions du Tour de France
en comptant celle de 2023 et bien 25
d'entre elles ont commencé à l'étranger
et même si la première délocalisation
date de 1954 déjà à l'époque donc
c'était à Amsterdam au Pays-Bas on voit
que la pratique c'est quand même pas mal
intensifiée dans les dernières décennies
la raison elle est principalement
économique ça rapporte gros aux
organisateurs qui font grimper le prix
pour le grand départ surtout quand il a
lieu à l'étranger l'an dernier par
exemple le Danemark accueillait trois
étapes et il a déboursé au total 6
millions d'euros pour pouvoir accueillir
ces étapes quant à Londres de son côté
au Royaume-Uni et bien la ville aurait
payé plus de 10 millions d'euros en 2007
c'est donc intéressant financièrement ça
permet aussi de développer le tour à
l'international et donc d'ailleurs
d'intéresser des diffuseurs étrangers
c'est là l'autre aspect intéressant d'un
point de vue financier pour ce tour la
question des droits TV au total
aujourd'hui 190
qui diffuse l'événement dont d'ailleurs
certains pays comme le Japon qui rêvent
qu'un jour et bien une étape soit
délocalisée là-bas pour des raisons
assez claires c'est pas forcément
évident aujourd'hui et pour vous donner
un ordre de grandeur les organisateurs
et donc à Maurice port organisation
touche près de 150 millions d'euros en
vendant leurs droits TV chaque année
quand on parle de droite TV c'est donc
les droits de diffusion par ces chaînes
un petit peu partout dans le monde et ça
représente près de 60% des recettes
globales du tour au passage cette
délocalisation à l'étranger elle a aussi
des conséquences politiques dans une
interview à France Info l'ex ministre
des Affaires étrangères Jean-Yves Le
Drian expliquer qu'il s'agissait aussi
d'un moyen d'étendre l'influence de la
France à l'étranger on parle alors de
soft power alors j'ai l'impression que
il y a pas une vidéo sur cette chaîne on
ne parle pas de soft power c'était le
cas notamment dans la vidéo sur l'Arabie
Saoudite le soft power c'est donc une
manière pour un pays d'influencer à
l'étranger ça peut être donc par le
biais de la culture ou encore du sport
et d'ailleurs il faut bien noter que le
Tour de France n'est pas la seule
compétition cycliste à avoir aujourd'hui
cette dimension internationales le Tour
d'Italie par exemple c'était exporté
pour une étape en Israël en 2018 alors
certains je le disais ici la dimension
diplomatique n'est pas le sujet premier
d'ASO c'est bien un intérêt avant tout
financier et d'ordre donc de visibilité
de l'événement pour ensuite le vendre
plus cher mais ça a bien donc aussi de
fait des conséquences politiques bref un
enjeu important pour les territoires et
pour les pays mais c'est aussi un enjeu
important d'un point de vue financier
évidemment pour les marques
[Musique]
en Formule 1 les marques ont des écuries
et bien en cyclisme c'est un petit peu
le même principe il y a 22 équipes
autour de France en 2023 et parmi elles
et bien on a par exemple l'équipe AG2R
Citroën team composé donc des
entreprises AG2R La Mondiale et Citroën
on a l'équipe évidemment Groupama FDJ
composé de Groupama et de la Française
des jeux on a aussi des équipes beaucoup
plus étonnantes comme par exemple
Bahreïn victorious une équipe qui
représente un gouvernement le
gouvernement du Bahreïn l'équipe a été
créée en 2017 à l'initiative du prince
du bahraïne lui-même et ça montre bien
d'ailleurs l'aspect diplomatique et
cette enjeu de soft power que j'évoquais
à l'instant on investissant dans le
cyclisme ces entités profitent ainsi de
la vitrine qu'offre le Tour de France
selon l'ex directeur général délégué
d'âge et2r LA MONDIALE ils vont breton
et bien les retomber médiatiques ont un
équivalent publicitaire 10 fois
supérieur à l'investissement bon et par
ailleurs évidemment comment parler de ce
sujet sans de cet aspect là le tour
possède aussi un immense espace de
publicité qu'on ne voit pas à la
télévision c'est évidemment la caravane
du Tour de France si vous êtes déjà allé
voir le passage du Tour vous le savez
sûrement avant le passage des cyclistes
des voitures à l'effigie des marques des
fils en balançant au public des petits
goodies on a tous entendu parler du
fameux Bob Cochonou que j'ai réussi à
récupérer de mon côté une année quand
j'étais petit au total il y a 70
véhicules festifs ils sont décorés aux
couleurs de 33 marques et chacune à
payer en moyenne 250 000 euros pour
avoir le droit d'être ici sur les trois
semaines et évidemment ce qui peut
arriver de mieux à une marque engagée
sur le Tour c'est bien sûr de gagner la
compétition et de repartir avec le
maillot jaune
c'est assez marrant après avoir vu tous
ces enjeux et notamment les enjeux
économiques de savoir en fait que le
Tour de France a été créé au départ pour
augmenter les ventes d'un journal papier
qui s'appelait l'auto à l'époque en tout
cas aujourd'hui et dans cette vidéo on
s'est beaucoup attardé sur l'aspect
économique politique et médiatique du
tout mais évidemment ça reste du sport
avant tout en tout cas j'espère que
cette vidéo vous aura plu n'hésitez pas
à vous abonner je me suis pas encore le
cas pour ne pas louper les vidéos
suivantes on en poste régulièrement sur
cette chaîne et on approche d'ailleurs
du million d'abonnés donc n'hésitez pas
à vous abonner je sais pas encore le cas
c'est un bon complément à la chaîne des
actualités du jour rendez-vous aussi sur
Instagram pour suivre d'autres
actualités au quotidien le nom du compte
c'est Hugo décrypse prenez soin de vous
prenez soin de vos proches et on se dit
à très vite